one of the more boring scenes from the
original Disney's Tarzan is what he
seemed as a little kid that is to say it
should have been interesting seeing a
half boy half ape trying to figure out
where he belongs should be downright
fascinating but instead it's just an
unfunny slapstick thrown in with
distracting Rosie O'Donnell ape and
aside from a scene where he puts mud on
his face trying to figure out what it is
it's just kind of generic so as you can
imagine I wasn't especially excited to
see Tarzan - which is already falsely
advertised is not Tarzan - it should be
called young Tarzan it's a prequel but
nevertheless I put it in and I'm not
gonna lie I really like this one yeah
not kind of enjoyed that found okay but
was legitimately charmed and entertained
by this Tarzan - why Tarzan - in fact
101 Dalmatians - why are these the two
Disney sequels so far I think are
actually pretty good these films should
be nothing but they're actually really
delightful the story like I said focuses
on Tarzan when he was a little boy he's
once again finding it hard to fit in and
figure out where he belongs but things
get even tougher when he's separated
from his family and they think he's dead
convinced that his family and his mother
would be better off without him he leads
the tribe to try and figure out where he
belongs along the way he comes across
some colorful characters a pair of
brothers played by Ron Perlman and Brad
Garrett their mother played by Estelle
Harris and an old ape pretending to be a
monster played by George Carlin he
befriends the old ape and makes a deal
that if he keeps convincing everybody
that he's a monster he'll help find out
what he is while that's going on Terk
the elephant and his mother all are
trying to find it while also trying to
escape some beautiful but deadly
landscapes so the important thing to
emphasize about this one is that it is a
smaller story it takes place when he's a
little kid so there's a lot of little
kid stuff there's a lot of slapstick
there's a lot of cute humor but a
slapstick and little kid stuff goes it's
really quite charming
I like these characters I like these two
brothers and their mother and how
they're all kind of dim-witted but
they're kind of threatening to when they
kind of go back and forth I like the old
ape and the relationship he shares with
Tarzan I like healthy people valued this
simple things and they kind of do these
nice little things for each other and I
don't know I just really felt a nice
connection between them and speaking of
which that's all the movie really is is
just watching these really good
connections work off of each other
most of the voice actors are back except
for the kid roles and that's including
Rosie O'Donnell she doesn't play the
younger version of herself and thank God
because the voice actors they got is a
million times better it sounds like a
real kid and she works off a Tarzan like
a real kid it doesn't feel like a forced
celebrity cameo it feels like there's a
real friendship
the turmoil Tarzan has to go through is
really well done this is the kind of
stuff I wanted to see in the original
movie now don't get me wrong we do get a
little bit of it when he's an adult but
this movie tends to dive more into it
the whole film is about him trying to
find his identity that's his goal that's
the beginning middle and end in the
other movie you got this bad guy who's
trying to kill all the gorillas and you
got him just doing some dumb comedic
stuff with Rosie O'Donnell and yeah I
liked it and it's a bigger story but it
didn't always work there were a lot of
times where it fell short and it felt a
little force here everything kind of
flows very naturally there's no one bad
guy there's no forced musical numbers
there's no awkward comedy everything
that needs to be done is done perfectly
in serving the story even the Phil
Collins songs which yes there are a few
are scaled down a lot I'm thinking again
here I'm all throughout this movie and
they're gonna piss me off but there's
only a couple when the movie needs a
quiet moment it has a quiet moment when
Tarzan's mom needs to just sit there
missing her son it lets her sit there
and miss her son you don't need Phil
Collins coming out think I'm sad I'm sad
I'm failed Collin okay I know a lot you
like Phil Collins but god I don't hate
Phil Collins
I'm sorry if you want the proof watch
this movie the emotional scenes are so
much better without his damn music I
don't necessarily blame him I blame the
fact that they chose to just go to a
Phil Collen song instead of letting the
story just flow naturally and for a
small quirky kind of movie everything
does really flow here I really get that
Tarzan is trying to figure out who he is
and that's where the focus is but that
doesn't mean there aren't some funny
moments or some quirky characters or
something that's really delightful now
does that make it better than the first
one well first of all it's amazing I'm
asking that at all but that's a little
trickier because the first one is a
bigger story it's supposed to be big and
grand and epic and well this is him as a
kid and supposed to be smaller and cute
but it does it so well that I really
wish it was in the first film and I get
it time constraints you can't do this
but on the other hand I have no problem
believing that this is part of the story
it's not like in Lion King
one-and-a-half where you don't really
believe Timon and Pumbaa were really
they're doing that stuff they just guys
shoehorned it in it really feels like
this was a part of his life growing up
and it's acted well and it's animated
well the drawings unlike Mulan - felt
like they could do the slapstick stuff
well and the emotional stuff just is
great in some respects I would almost
rather watch this than the original
again I'm not saying it's necessarily
better I'm saying it screws up less than
the first one there's so many times in
the first film I remember rolling my
eyes like oh we're doing this thing
dammit we were going so well can we do
this instead of that but here it does
everything that it's supposed to do and
even taking this story that yeah we've
kind of heard a few times before but the
way they tell it it seems like you're
hearing it for the first time it's like
How to Train Your Dragon yeah we've seen
that setup to death but when it's done
in a unique and passionate way it's
really enjoyable to watch I don't know
I'm still a little too close to it to
declare which one is better but yeah I
actually did kind of like watching this
one a little bit more than the first one
I liked it a great deal and I have no
shame in saying that I like the
characters I like the animation I like
the story I like the backgrounds I like
the acting I like the music it's just
good it's a good Disney sequel I don't
know why it's this and 101 Dalmatians
too but both of these I wouldn't mind
seeing again I'm sure a lot of people
are going to disagree with me and that's
fine but from my point of view this is a
movie I could swing in to watch again
you